on dit souvent que le sport est à la
base de tout à travers les valeurs de
solidarité et de respect les jeunes se
découvrent accompagné de Jean-Marc
mormec exemple très courtisé de réussite
sportive la ministre des Sports Valérie
FOURNERON a visité les ateliers au
château de versaill pour la 3è journée
du sport scolaire au sein des
associations sportives les élèves
découvrent de nombreuses disciplines et
accèdent parfois au niveau ça leur
permet de de se former en tant que
citoyen et puis ensuite ce sont vraiment
des les élèves qui du coup
s'investissent dans tout à la fois la
réparation du bateau le respect du
matériel le respect du cadre et c'est
vraiment intéressant pour eux certains
d'entre eux ont déjà acquis un excellent
niveau ils ont déjà participé au
championnat de France à plusieurs
reprises en slalom en course en ligne
via les championnat de France UNSS et
aussi au niveau des championnats de
France fédéraux le sport c'est aussi le
moyen pour les jeunes en difficulté
scolaire de ne pas décrocher pour
certains jeunes qui sont mal dans leur
peau et bien réussir dans le domaine du
sport peut leur permettre de réaccrocher
sur un certain nombre de disciplines on
peut par le sport on peut parfois aussi
par la culture par la musique avoir le
déclic qui fait que le jeune se retrouve
bien à l'école et retrouve le goût des
apprentissages mais sans les professeurs
de PS l'UNSS et les associations
sportives au sein des collèges et lycées
ne pourrai pas tenir debout nos
enseignants de PS font ce magnifique
travail et je voudrais les saluer tous
ce magnifique de travail de permettre
d'accompagner chacune et chacun en
fonction de ses
de permettre de découvrir de découvrir à
la fois son autonomie son corps et puis
si on en a la possibilité d'aller plus
loin sur cette pratique compétitive
depuis 2007 7000 postes de professeurs
de PS ont été créés l'UNSS et la 3è
fédération sportive de
France